roger germann bonsoir vous avez 65 ans
vous êtes président du crif depuis 2001
après une carrière dans la banque
rothschild alors au dîner du crif c'est
une tradition tous les ans il ya des des
ministres les députés et des
responsables religieux dans cette année
y avait nicolas sarkozy dominique perben
michèle alliot marie
xavier darcos patrick devedjian jean
louis debré laurent fabius bertrand
delanoë alain juppé ya du monde quand
même seulement alors devant tous ces
gens vous avez déclaré que
l'antisionisme est le nouvel habit de
l'antisémitisme et vous avez parlé de
cette fameuse alliance rouge brun vert
alors les rouges c'est lui c'est
l'extrême gauche c'est la lcr c'est
arlette aussi les bras mais c'est
l'extrême droite c'est le pen
les verts sz et les écolos et
contrairement à ce que dit à john baird
les verts pour vous c'est pas la couleur
de l'islam c'est bien c'est bien les
verts c'est bien le parti de monsieur le
maire c'est ça fait donc il eu raison de
partir
non il n'y a pas eu de raison de partir
d'abord besoin de se sentir visés en
tous les cas
écoutez on l'a invité c'est qu'on
voulait pouvoir dialoguer avec lui je
regrette qu'il soit parti si vite
il aurait d'abord assisté à un repas
manger des légumes verts et et aurait
entendu la fin de mon discours et le
discours du premier ministre
on a parlé de choses importantes voilà
au sujet de la lcr parce que c'est lui
qu'elle a ce soir vous allez parler de
courants d'extrême gauche anti
mondialiste anti capitaliste anti
américains et anti sioniste est ce que
vous pensez pas quand même qu'il ya un
petit peu d' amalgame dans tout ça donc
si vous voulez moi ça ne me gêne pas
qu'il soit anticapitaliste ou anti
américains ça c'est de la politique
économie une politique là où là où il ya
des dérives qui me gêne beaucoup c'est
quand à partir de l'antisionisme et et
la critique de la politique de sharon me
paraît tout à fait acceptable c'est une
démocratie en israël c'est une
démocratie en france parfaitement le
droit d'être opposé à la politique de
charolles lawzi là où il ya danger c'est
qu'au delà de la critique quand on tente
on va la diffamation quand on va à la
démonisation à la diabolisation et qu'on
dit que des israéliens sont néo nazis
qu'ils possèdent un génocide qu'il
pratique de l'apartheid
à ce moment là
disent allez les mecs de lcn et des
panneaux qu'on voit dans les
manifestations elle dit ça très
clairement jusqu'à handicap avec on voit
la bande à kevin
il a réagi à vos propos 1 mais non mais
ce sont selon lui est apportée à la
crise n'a dit que c'était une insulte
une campagne de terrorisme intellectuel
visant à couvrir le terrorisme d'état
d'israël un amalgame scandaleux
krivine toute critique politique de
sharon dutil était assimilé à
d'antisémitisme lorsque ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que cette critique
elle me paraît légitime et normal par
contre quand on va diaboliser on risque
des dérapages et ses dérapages ont des
conséquences
je vous en donner pour preuve un article
que que j'ai ici et qui parle de la
chasse aux juifs dans un collège le
collège dans à paris dans le 20ème
arrondissement où un garçon de 11 ans
est persécuté par ses camarades de
classe parce que il a eu le malheur de
lire une plaque vont rappeler la mémoire
de juifs disparus pendant la shoah
et depuis ce moment-là on le on le
traite de sale juif on le bat on le
bouscule on le traite de ariel sharon et
on l'accuse d'avoir tué les palestiniens
et je crois que c'est un article qui
mérite réflexion et je le passe à
monsieur besancenot
je suis sûr qu'il le lire avec le plus
grand intérêt et je signale que cet
article a été publié dans un journal non
juifs qui est le journal du dimanche et
que le journaliste qui l'a écrit n'est
pas juif non plus besancenot m'écoutais
je vais vous dire les choses calmement
mais calmement dans les yeux je voudrais
dire que vos propos et vos amalgames non
pas simplement en révolte et ça m'a
meurtrie
ça m'a blessée parce que moi vous savez
j'ai l'antifascisme et l'antiracisme à
fleur de peau et la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
c'est dans mon projet de société comme
tout celui de la lcr et mes premiers pas
vous le découvrez pas messieurs kuperman
un peu de un peu de un peu de calme
quand même je les premiers pas en
politique vous savez quand j'ai fait
débrayé pour la première fois mon lycée
que j'ai mis en grève
c'est au moment du pillage du cimetière
juif de carpentras vous savez que la lcr
a toujours été aux côtés de la
communauté juive y compris récemment
quand il y avait des synagogues brute
et quand il y avait des agressions
racistes on l'a rappelé et je rappelle
d'ailleurs ce soir à toute la communauté
juive toute ma sympathie ce que vous
faites c'est un amalgame honteux parce
que vous jouez sur l' amalgame et si
vous pensez sincèrement monsieur
kuperman que dans la france
d'aujourd'hui où jean marie le pen fait
18% que vos adversaires que les
adversaires de la communauté juive
c'est les antimondialistes c'est les
verts c'est la confédération paysanne
c'est nous alors franchement je comprend
pas mais malheureusement alors je vais
vous donner un autre papier puisque on
en est là je crois que vous en êtes pas
votre première ambiguïté puisque je me
rappelle de votre déclaration dans le
monde à propos de l'arrivée de le pen au
deuxième tour en expliquant que j'espère
que l'arrivée de le pen au 2è tour
constituera un message aux musulmans
leur a dit qu'en de se tenir tranquille
alors monsieur kuperman je vous le
redonne j'espère que vous me dites ray
cette question j'espère simplement que
vous avez confiance conscience qui si
vous devez représenter les intérêts de
la communauté juive passe au chairman
audi c'est des propos qui n'ont pas été
tenus au journal le monde mais un
journaliste
ce sont des propos qui ont été tenus
dans un journal israélien qui ont été
rapportés alors c on dit que il a dit
qu' on dit que moi ce que je dis j'ai
toujours affirmé c'est le rôle du crif
c'est évident c'est que nous luttons
contre l'antisémitisme d'où qu'ils
viennent
tantôt il vient de droite et je vous la
corde c'est une maladie honteuse de la
france que l'extrême droite française
c'est clair parce que la lcr est en 6 et
8 je me pose la question parce que c'est
les propos que vous avez tenus ce
week-end mais il arrive il arrive qu'il
y ait des propos tenus dans les
manifestations où vous êtes vous appeler
au boycott des universités israéliennes
vous appeler au boycott des sociétés
israéliennes qui n'ont rien à voir avec
la politique du gouvernement israélien
c'est une attitude de citer ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure sur la politique
du gouvernement israélien sur l'armée
d'occupation
l'armée d'occupation en israël c'est une
armée du peuple chaque individu fait
trois ans de service militaire pour les
garçons 2 ans pour les filles fait un
mois de service militaire par année de
réserve
ils sont là pour défendre leurs enfants
à leurs frères qui se font exploser dans
les autobus et qu'est ce que vous voulez
phase aller à l'armée israélienne y en a
même qui ont témoigné en disant qu'il va
le puy ce boulot là il n'y avait pas
beaucoup la plupart ya une solidarité
mais c'est vrai que josé bové c'est
qu'il n'est pas elles servent enfin
c'est un anti mondialiste un anti
capitaliste a parlé de purification
ethnique en ce qui concerne les
territoires occupés et au retour de
ramallah où il était allé rencontrer
yasser arafat josé bové il a dit que
c'était le mossad qui mettait des bombes
devant les synagogues ça c'est vrai il
l'a dit il s'en est excusé après mais
l'a dit donc ceux qui essayent de
l'aviron g kuperman c'est aussi quand
même qu'il ya un espèce d'état d'esprit
qu'il faut pas tout mélanger il faut
surtout pas tout mélanger non mais
attendez quand on dit par exemple que
dans des manifestations
pro-palestiniennes auquel j'ai participé
ni eu des propos antisémites je dis que
c'est faux c'est arrivé qu'une seule
fois
il ya des clashs êtes vous le savez bien
vous n'avez jamais elle sert vous n'avez
jamais tant d'années quand même s'il
vous plaît
c'est faux on s'en est d'ailleurs
expliqué avec le consistoire de la
douzaine d'années absolument on a fait
même mieux que ça avec les lâchers qui
est la responsable de l'accord de
l'autorité palestinienne en france on a
coupé la manifestation en deux parce
qu'il y aura jamais un slogans
antisémites dans une manifestation dans
son listing je suis écouté une chose
écoutez une seule chose moi les débats
politiques je suis prêt à les entendre y
compris discuter israël palestine mais
ne mélangez pas tout n'exporter pas ce
conflit ici avec la mienne mais j'ai
peur que vous soyez aveuglés par votre
fanatisme pro sharon bowles mélangez pas
bien écouté
vous accusez vous nous accusez de
communautariser nous sommes les victimes
de la communautarisation on attaque nos
synagogues on attaque n'aura pas nous on
n'a jamais attaqué ni lait ni des imams
des mosquées
on est absolument des victimes et nous
ne sommes qu'en quand on attaque des
enfants dans les écoles quand on dit
qu'ils sont des sales juifs et aux
autres qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'ils
fassent les parents ils les envoient
dans des écoles privées
c'est dramatique pour la c6 r mad 16
c'est très mauvais ce dimanche énormes
sommes les victimes c'est vous inversez
rapport anal héros de ce week end mais
c'est
cinquante ans que les verts quant au
congrès des verts dans l'hiver vous
m'avez en face pour une fois on met
alors je vous demande vous propose la
question y'a pas y'a pas il n'y a pas
énormément de différence sur cette
question là entre les verrez vous vous
vous le reconnaissez d'ailleurs vous
défendez les dangers qu kerman est-ce
que ce soir vous revenez sur les propos
que j'ai tenus samedi
ou est ce que voulait maintenant je les
maintiens car il me paraît essentiel que
ce soit l'occasion de vider un abcès
avec les verts et j'ai d'ailleurs reçu
une lettre et avec éventuellement
d'autres
j'ai reçu une lettre du secrétaire
nationale des verts et j'espère que nous
pourrons aborder à fond ces questions il
est quand même anormal qu'au congrès des
verts est un monsieur qui crient vive le
ramasse le ramasse vaincre avec c'est
pas vrai vous savez que j'aurais été
démentie monsieur mamère a démenti or il
ya une journaliste de france inter qui
contrairement à ce qu'il disait n'est
pas juive a assisté était moins du fait
qu'il a dit là il y avait 30 personnes
dont une journaliste donc il l'a dit
vous n'avez pas peur monsieur kuperman
d' importer en france le conflit
israélo-palestinien encore une fois nous
n'avons nous jamais importé aucun acte
de violence nous n'avons jamais agressé
une mosquée où un imam et c'est nous qui
sommes des victimes
on nous agresse donc c'est pas nous qui
est important le conflit on nous
l'important nous le met sur le dos et on
ou communautariste de cette manière là
est-ce que vous avez pas peur qu'on vous
accuse comme à l'époque de double
allégeance
écoutez j'ai dit et je répète moi j'ai
le droit d'aimer mon père et ma mère est
donc le problème moi le droit d'être
d'être breton catholique et d'aimer la
cornemuse et d'être français pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas le droit
d'avoir de de lui une affection
particulière de la même manière
d'ailleurs que que les musulmans
français ont de la sympathie pour la
cause palestinienne
ce que je trouve absolument normal pense
quoi moi non c'est pas parce qu'il ya un
excité dans une dans une manifestation
dans lequel on peut retrouver des verts
et des roses a beaucoup quelques excités
sur lequel des caméras se braquent parce
qu'effectivement c'est marquant c'est
remarquable sens presque le tireur du
texte littéraire du terme de voir un
slogan comme ça il faut en faire pour
autant c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
imaginer et je peux pense pas
sincèrement vous puissiez imaginer au
sein de la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire et des verts
une forte majorité et à courants
susceptibles déjà vont inviter l'homme
singe je veux qu'on allait mettre les
bruns mais mélanger les bras au milieu
c'est vrai que c'est très difficile en
inde pour quelqu'un qui a des
convictions à gauche quoi même si on
sait qu'il ya des négationnistes et ils
viennent de l'extrême gauche que c'était
observait on ne peut pas accepter que
des verts impunément dire des choses
comme il les on dit tous que josé bové
disent des choses impunément comme il
lui a dit je suis étonné qu'on ne parle
pas des autres conflits de la guerre
civile en algérie qui a fait 200 mille
morts je n'entends pas la lcr on parlait
plaisantez ou quoi
pas beaucoup en tout cas il parle plus
du conflit du proche orient que du
conflit de l'algérie on n'entend pas
parler et je ne parle pas du soudan où
il ya un million de morts de votre
soutien autrefois paul pope qui était
votre grand ami paul potts bien entendu
on regarde mais vous voyez les derrière
moi bon bah c'était faux enfin vous
rigolez comme c'était mentionnés dans
ces accusations c'est ce que tiago c'est
seul vous comptiez cuba vous aimez bien
où il souhaitait moi mais moi c'est
plutôt le che guevara vous savez tout ce
que j'ai retrouvés à porto allègre y
compris des jeunes israéliens qui se
battent pour la paix qui renierait tous
beaucoup de ces firmes anouk racines
dans l'est dans les yeux de ces jeunes
israéliens qui était à porto allègre et
de ces jeunes américains j'ai vu de
l'espoir j'ai vu de l'amour je vis de la
paix dont vos yeux avoue choix de la
haine depuis le début des propos qui
sont diffamatoires
la communauté juive en france les et les
israéliens ne veulent qu'une chose c'est
la paix ils ont offerte à quand des vies
elle a malheureusement été refusée c'est
un drame épouvantable ce refus de
l'offre de paix qui a été fait à ce
moment-là parce que il y aurait on
aurait économisé ses 3000 morts et les
choses seraient seraient seraient
aujourd'hui là où elles seront un jour
parce que la création d'un état
palestinien et est évidente et l'accord
pour la création de cet état palestinien
se fera sur les bases approximative de
candé vide et de tabac c'est évident
donc on a perdu plusieurs années et on
perdra peut-être malheureusement encore
plusieurs années jusqu'à ce que les
israéliens les palestiniens se mettre
vraiment autour d'une table avec la
volonté de faire la paix d'accepter
l'existence de l'autre c'est bien ce que
nous voulons de curcuma ne se fait une
proposition vous retirer les propos vous
avez eu en taxant la lcr à mi-mots
d'antisémitisme je suis je vous propose
de discuter tous les sujets que vous
voudrez mais ce jour là uniquement pas
d'un mâle gamme s'il vous plaît parce
que c'est quelque chose qui me touche
profondément
et tous ceux qui sont derrière moi moi
je ne voudrais pas qu'on mette de co2
conditions la liane d'ailleurs à
désavouer vos propos et vous le savez
comme moi et c'est tant mieux je ne mets
pas de condition au dialogue s'ils
voulaient dialoguer je suis tout à fait
ou presque à log
vous êtes prêt ce soir à redire
organisations anti sionisme parce que ça
on a le droit d'être anti sioniste je
vous dis à des juifs qui j'en ai dit les
jeunes d au moins d'antisémitisme non
mais je je ne dis pas que tous les
membres de la lcr où tous les membres
des verts ou de la lutte ouvrière sont
des antisémites du mondial tout ça est
ce que pour vous je suis un antisémite
je vous pose la question écoutez je vous
ai vu participer à des tas de
manifestations dans lesquelles on
traitait les juifs de nazis et ça c'est
un fait les propos diffamatoires vous
savez le consistoire le set
toutes les organisations de la
communauté via diallo et g
défaut j'espère du fond du coeur moi
j'ai vu la communauté juive arrêtera se
faire représenter par des gens comme
vous et je lui rappelle toute ma
sympathie ce soir mais je pense qu'avec
des propos diffamatoires comme ça c'est
probablement juste se termina je vais
vous dire c est ce que mon corps on est
quand même malheureux que vous utilisiez
ce type de propos alors que nous n'avons
qu'un souhait c'est de faire la paix et
je ne crois pas que vous y contribuez de
cette manière là il vend non mais moi
juste j'ai grandi dans un environnement
de communistes et on a toujours à la
maison défendu la différence ce soit des
noirs et des arabes ce soit des juifs
est évidemment entre communistes et elle
sert il ya peut-être effectivement une
différence mais je sais pas je prends ça
aussi pour moi et moi sommes vraiment ça
me fait mal quoi parce que dans les
camps il y avait des cocos il y avait
des tziganes y avait des juifs et il y
avait des il y avait des homosexuels et
et ils ont tous lutter ensemble et les
gens qui ont pris le maquis en 47 aussi
d'une certaine façon serrée pour
défendre ça et puis alors et là vous
nous ramenez sa fâchez pas je trouve ça
écoutez on regarde la télé tous les
soirs et on voit des mômes qui balancent
des pierres contre des chars et vous
venez là avec c'est avec cette avec
cette polémique là et je ne pense pas
que ça aille dans le bon sens je ne
pense pas que les gens soient là excusez
moi je pense pas que l'urgence elles
viennent le danger vienne des partis
d'extrême gauche c'est pas ça bien
votre dernier mot roger kuperman je
souhaite la paix la paix au proche
orient puis la paix entre nous également
c'est mal barré olivier votre dernier
mot je pense je pense ce soir à une
grande partie de la direction
d'organisations qui pendant des années
des années a subi les pires quolibets
s'est fait traiter de juifs dans la rue
a eu son lot de martyrs dans les camps
de concentration et qui doit ce soir est
particulièrement intérêts ne mesurons
pas le nombre de juifs morts je crois
que heureusement
malheureusement le gazon ne surtout pas
merci roger du karma psy
[Applaudissements]
à
c'est pas les remercie
ça passe par ça passe pas il ya des
insultes qui passe pas ouais ça peut
s'arranger vous croyez j'espère pour lui
ouais il dit quoi krivine de ça il
faudrait lui demander
ouais
et se retrouver la sphère traite à
mi-mots d'antisémite c'est dur en tous
les cas ça prouve que vous avez du coeur
que la révolution c'est aussi une
affaire d'amour va s'écrire dans l'it
merci d'avoir accès à des îles pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de inler 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux